cracks in China's economy are getting
harder for Beijing to ignore as a
crumbling real estate market and Fallout
from China's zero covered strategy start
to hit where it hurts signs of a policy
change have some saying things this
could be a turning point but will it be
enough to stop the downward slide of the
world's second largest economy
I'm Christy platson in Berlin with your
DW business special and joining me today
we have George Magnus he's an associate
at Oxford University's China Center
George thank you so much for joining us
today
now now you've also written a book Red
Flags uh red flags why XI jinping's
China is in Jeopardy uh love the title
by the way love a good pun
um so before we jump into this week's
news you published this book back in
2018 already so what red flags were
jumping out at you at that time
the the
news that I think were already pretty
evident at that time were
firstly how China was going to deal with
its kind of mounting burden of debt to
which it had become increasingly
addicted so it had had a very successful
economic development model for many
years but eventually
um as it always happens with emerging
countries it gives way needs to change
and and the government was very
reluctant to change so uh the debt
burden was one of the red flags the
demographics were another because China
is the fastest aging country on uh in
the planet I'm not the oldest but the
fastest aging the third big flag red
flag was productivity so after Decades
of very rapid productivity growth it had
actually stalled
um and then uh there were kind of other
ones that were looming like changes in
governance so you know uh XI jinping's
China was becoming much more kind of
leninist in terms of its approach to
politic politics into economic manage
management and then of course the
external environment was was already in
2018-19
um had already succumbed to president
Trump's trade War since then of course
it's become much worse and much more
um involved so those are the Red Flags
basically
right well I mean since then we've we
have seen or it's seeming like the high
paced growth that China had been seeing
some years ago is starting to come to an
end and we've had more developments on
top of the ones you just mentioned uh
coveted lockdowns Russia's war against
Ukraine trade disputes with the West
these have all put severe restraints on
Chinese economic growth so if we take a
look at the figures in 2010 the economy
grew more than 10 percent but growth has
been slowing ever since then it was
particularly low in 2020 when the
pandemic effect really started to bite
in China and around the globe I should
say the growth rate this year will be
3.2 percent according to a Reuters poll
of analysts so this is not even close to
the government's Target of 5.5 percent
and China has said it needs to maintain
growth at that rate if it's going to
provide enough jobs for all the young
people who want to enter the labor
market
so George a passive China Watcher might
take a look at the last 10 years and
think that China has actually been doing
really well we've seen a lot of
interesting things coming out of there
the Belton Road initiative which is of
course an infrastructure development
project going on around the world also
in terms of of tech we've seen Tick Tock
Huawei ride hailing apps we've seen
China's Central Bank really pushing the
digital currencies Trend
um but if we look at these economic
growth numbers this is painting a
different picture of of China so could
you break down this contradiction for me
yeah I think it's it's really important
that you should mention that and also
for us all to sort of contextualize
right so Number One China is the second
biggest economy in the world measured in
uh well measured in the way most people
would measure it which is in in current
US dollar terms there are other ways of
measuring it but let's not get into the
the long grass there so it's the second
biggest economy in the world so it's
around 17 to 18 trillion dollars in size
um it's the biggest export nation in the
world
um it's uh you know got a very sort of
Highly Educated Urban Workforce
um it's capable of creating and is
creating a lot of Advanced Technologies
in things like mobile payments for
example it's for real world leader
everybody's heard of some of the big
Chinese companies like Huawei for
example so you know we're not talking
about a basket case developing country
here
um uh but there is a contradiction uh as
you point out because within that
context
um China's growth model its development
model is basically has run into a brick
wall
um and there's a problem here because
very successful countries uh often get
into this or frequently get into this
problem this uh situation where uh the
success of the development model you
know is not Eternal it has to be changed
sometimes it runs it needs it has new
requirements it needs to be rebooted but
of course the problem with change is
that you need very flexible institutions
um and consensus to be able to make
important changes in the way in which
your economy and your politics work the
trouble in China of course is that the
Communist party is very rigid in its
view and very controlling in its
attitude to everything from industry to
the economy society and everything you
can think of so the problem if I want to
kind of encapsulate it really is that
China's development model on which the
legitimacy of the Communist party is
based at home and also to some degree uh
in the big wide world that development
model is is no longer fit for purpose
and it's very there isn't really an
alternative the government knows it has
to be changed but they're not really
willing or able to take the political
measures to really be able to change it
in the way that we would normally expect
well so talking a little bit more
specifically about people in China for a
second uh now we heard yesterday that um
Alibaba which is basically China's
Amazon reported major losses and this is
um often seen or Alibaba is often seen
as a reflection of consumer sentiment in
China so that's not really you know
giving the best impression for regular
Chinese people what is life like for
them in China right now
well uh it's it's pretty tough in a way
I mean obviously there are there is no
one China right there are uh lots of
people uh who have living standards
income ahead the same as for example
Portugal many of these people live in
the coastal cities for example the
tourists go and visit we used to go and
visit before covid
um hopefully we'll do again
um but there was also a China which is
uh the so-called Backwater so the rural
areas uh the sort of central areas some
of the central areas the Northeast the
west of China here income living
standards and income ahead are really
still quite low
so um what is life like for Chinese
consumers it kind of depends where you
are in China for uh Urban consumers
let's say in Beijing or Shanghai it's
kind of rough but not kind of the end of
the world it's rough because they've had
to succumb to
um the disciplines of zero covid and
frequent lockdowns and so on it's rough
because the hospitality Leisure
entertainment Industries for example
service Industries haven't really been
able to function the property Market has
rolled over after like 20 years of Boom
um so things are looking a little bit
tougher for you know if you're poorer if
you happen to be on the kind of low end
of the income distribution you live in a
you're a migrant one of 300 migrant
workers in Chinese cities and you don't
get access to free education Social
Services Healthcare and so on
um yeah things are not that great to be
honest the consumer is having a bit of a
rough time many consumers are yeah
certainly and I mean I'm sure the zirad
covet strategy China's pursued
um isn't making life more comfortable
comfortable for them now I mean Beijing
has indicated it would perhaps ease
these restrictions slightly but experts
are saying that it's not going to mean
uh make a whole lot of difference um at
least in the shorter midterm here how
much pain has the zero covet strategy
caused for China or for Chinese people
how would you respond to that question
quite a lot and I think you know social
media have certainly been has been full
uh in recent months of um video clips
that people have posted about lockdowns
in Shanghai or in Guangzhou at the
moment or in other you know cities
um where people and you know and long
lines for testing where people have to
be tested twice or three times
um a day or in frequently during the
week and obviously the regime is quite
rough so it is being relaxed a little
bit
um or it has been during the last couple
of weeks and this has given rise to
speculation that there may be you know
these are the baby steps that the
government needs to take to eventually
leave behind an abandoned zero covid
perhaps next March or April we'll see
um I mean so far uh it doesn't look like
the government has a really sort of
coherent plan because if you really want
to leave zero code behind you have to
have lots of mRNA vaccines you have to
vaccinate the over 60s in the over 80s
only about 40 percent of the over 80s
have been vaccinated
um you have to have plenty of Hospital
capacity to deal with um ICU cases I
mean emergency cases especially for
older citizens none of this is in situ
yet so um I think it'll be quite some
time before China really leaves zero
covered behind but they may if they have
a decent winter and the caseload doesn't
increase too much they may be able to
carry on uh relaxing the the policy but
they also may not if uh if things get
out of hand so the next few weeks I
think will be very telling
now George making uh making a jump to a
more International perspective now we um
obviously saw energy markets going into
turmoil earlier this year after Russia
invaded Ukraine
um this has created a lot of
conversation a lot of anxieties in
Western countries about uh being over
overly reliant on certain countries for
certain things for example like the eu's
dependence on Russia for gas and oil
these same anxieties are now popping up
about dependencies on China I'd like
your thoughts on this in just a second
but first DW spoke with Siemens CEO
Roland Bush this week about what
resilience against such dependencies
means for his company
but we have to acknowledge that
resilience is also has also a price so
therefore it is worthwhile investing now
in new markets and diversifying but on
top on top of what we do in China so for
me this is also the strategy what
Siemens is doing that we can continue
investing in in China we want to keep or
even increase our market share there
there's nothing bad about it taking the
chances we have but at the same time
looking into other markets with a
stronger focus and grow our business
there too
now George in your opinion is China
worried about uh the talks of of moving
into other markets aside from China
um I I think they are and I think they
should be
um not as as the you know as you've just
heard I mean I don't know whether
Siemens is representative of you know
tens of thousands of companies that are
in China I should think it has a pretty
big um
um say as or kind of represents
certainly what what big companies think
which is you know they don't want to
leave China they still see virtue and
value in increasing their revenues and
taking advantage of the the growth in
the Chinese market but all companies I
think are having to reconsider uh their
Reliance on sole source suppliers you
know particularly inside China and of
becoming caught in the crosshairs of
geopolitics where they may have to
choose and companies are not in business
to do this but they are and may have to
choose more about whose rules and
regulations they're going to follow and
whose rules regulations they're in a
flout that in other words they won't
follow and that's because of the not
just because of the sanctions regimes
that have been introduced over since
young Province over the treatment of
Hong Kong over
um you know risk of secondary sanctions
on companies in China
if they break primary sanctions against
Russia but also of course in the future
if things should go really horribly
wrong in terms of international
relations and China were to threaten or
become bellicos over Taiwan the
likelihood is very strong that there
will be
um huge changes in policies by the
United States probably the EU as well I
would say in terms of its trade and
Commercial and political relations with
with China and so you know it's it's
prudent for companies to be able to to
now kind of look at other countries in
Asia and beyond for changing the supply
chains that have taken decades to to
build up it won't happen quickly but I'm
pretty sure it is starting to happen now
yeah certainly the situation in Ukraine
has everyone looking at Taiwan for just
the reasons you you just said well so
Switching gears again another major
development this week had to do with
China's real estate market so to to zoom
in on that for a second here the China
housing market crash is oh pardon me one
second here
the China housing market crash is
threatening
to expand into a wider financial crisis
the country's largest property developer
like evergrand are sagging under large
debt burdens and consumers are losing
their investments in failed construction
projects more and more people are
reluctant to buy new homes and that's
why prices for newly built houses are
falling November last year prices of a
newly built home was three were three
percent higher than a year earlier
houses seem to be a good investment but
the latest figure from October this
year's shows that prices for newly built
homes are down 1.6 percent it was the
sixth straight month of decreases in new
home prices and the fastest fall since
2015. this is really bad news for the
economy as the real estate sector
accounts for about 30 percent of China's
GDP now so George back to you talking
about housing being a good investment
for people in China I understand it's
also one of the only options for
Investing For for people there what role
does home ownership play in China What's
the culture around that
it's pretty big um I mean basically
households hold their wealth really
in only two ways one is in the form of
property and the other is in the form of
bank deposits so there isn't really that
sort of financial infrastructure that
I'm sure you know a lot of the citizens
in richer countries are quite accustomed
to and don't even think about really
which is the Investments that they may
either hold directly in stocks and in
bonds or through insurance policies or
through asset management companies and
so on so obviously the Chinese Financial
authorities hope that in time foreign
Financial firms will bring know-how and
capital to China to help Chinese
citizens diversify the way in which they
hold their wealth but for the moment
most of Chinese wealth is held in the
form of of property
so that means that when prices are
falling and when the the market is in uh
in a pretty dire state which it is now
and actually prices are falling much
more quickly in so-called tier 3 and
tier 4 cities which are lower
administratively uh kind of ranked
cities that say Beijing or Shenzhen for
example or Shanghai
um so these cities where most of the
housing stock is and where most of the
over capacity exists are seeing price
declines much bigger than the the
numbers that you mentioned and so it's
really important for the government to
try to stabilize this if it can
right well uh hopping off of that point
china has introduced this 16 point plan
exactly to do this to stabilize the
property Market it's empowering
Regulators in the central bank to
promote the stable and healthy
development of a sector that generates
as much as a third of gross gross
domestic product the measures include
support for overstretched housing
developers the government wants to make
sure that pre-sold projects are finished
to avoid protests by mortgage holders
there will be deferred payment loan
options for home buyers and lower
mortgage down payments also looser
purchasing rules on first homes by new
city dwellers
yeah I mean these measures
um are precisely the antithesis of the
kinds of things the government was
trying to do in 2020 and 2021 when Xi
Jinping was very adamant about you know
houses are for living in not
hello
yeah sorry George yeah go on
yeah
yep
I think we might have lost do we have
George still
yeah yeah I'm still here I just got I
was just mid flow when somebody said can
you hear me uh sorry well can you pick
up your flow again there you were
talking about this being the opposite of
uh uh you can carry on now I was with
you
okay so okay wait sorry quick question
pause George we're going to start over
um from my little introduction and then
we'll just go back into it okay
okay
all right no worries
all right one second guys
okay so I'll just start up here with
well China has introduced a 16-point
plan to do exactly this to stabilize the
property Market it empowers regulators
and the central bank to promote the
quote stable and healthy development of
a sector that generates as much as a
third of gross domestic product in China
the measures include support for
overstretched housing developers the
government wants to make sure pre-sold
projects are actually finished to avoid
protests by mortgage holders there will
be deferred payment loan options for
home buyers and lower mortgage down
payments also lure looser purchasing
rules on first homes by new city
dwellers George what's your reaction to
this plan
because it's really it's the antithesis
of pretty much everything the government
was trying to do in 2020 and 2021 when
decision being insisted that housing was
for living in not for speculation so we
had these huge uh and quite important
restraints imposed on developers
um and on housing conditions and
mortgage conditions and so on but the
pain looks to have been too much for the
authorities and I think they've now
backtracked and have tried to alleviate
some of that pain for developers and for
mortgage holders but of course the
problem is most of the measures that
have been announced in this 16-point
plan will try to it'll stretch out uh
the problems that are being faced by
local governments property developers
and mortgage owners but it won't solve
the problem of rein reinvigorating
demand for housing and the kind of
momentum that the market was used to
before so I think I think the effect if
it has an the effect will be temporary
and the long-term or medium-term
implications for the housing market are
still pretty bearish actually largely
because you know there's too much debt
falling prices and um the the
demographic of first-time buyers looks
pretty awful
well yeah George just uh to wrap up my
last question what would be exactly off
of that if you don't see these moves
reinvigorating uh China what
developments do you see on the horizon
and what might that mean for the rest of
the world
well I think that what we have to get
used to is a China that's going to grow
by about two and a half to three percent
over the next 10 years rather than you
know 10 which is kind of what people
think they still might get back to or
eight percent sometimes people say but
it's going to be much more pedestrian in
the future and the only question really
is not whether China will grow more
slowly but whether it'll be a kind of a
relatively more or less stable
environment and that depends very much
on the kinds of uh policies the
government takes to try to change the
way in which growth is generated if it
tries to keep pump priming the economy
with infrastructure and real estate
um it's not going to look very pretty to
be honest if it tries to move more
towards consumers and service Industries
which would require political change
which is a tall order that might be a
lot better but I think the odds at the
moment are not very favorable for that
outcome
well we're going to have to leave it
there for now but George I want to thank
you so much for joining us on the show
this is George Magnus China expert at
Oxford University and if you'd like to
add some context to our talk today I
would encourage you to check out the
latest episode of DW's business Beyond
which looks at the likelihood of the
next Global recession in 2023 and why
this time it's personal
I'm Christy pladson from DW business
until next time take care
foreign